Now we're going to allow the user to
create new notes by tapping a button.
When we have to add a new cell for the
table, notify the table so it reloads.
The beauty of core data is that
it takes care of all of that.
So let's create the new method.
Try it out and
see what's actually happening.
First let's add an add button and
link it to an IB action.
Now, we get to implement this action.
And you might want to think a little
bit about what should go in here.
Creating a new note seems like
the obvious thing so let's start there.
Okay, so we have our new note, but
now do we have to do anything else?
Should we update the table view?
Well you think about it.
I'll go ahead and run the app.
So we have a storyboard which
is updated with an add button
which is linked to an IB action.
Now, we get to implement this action and
you might want to think a little
bit about what should go in here.
Creating a new note seems like
the obvious thing so let's start there.
Now do we have to do anything else?
Should we update the table view?
While you think about it,
I'll go ahead and run the app.
Tada magic.
Well, I don't know about you, but
I usually want to see how
a magic trick actually works.
So who's actually getting
the job done here?
It's the MVC, the notifications,
and the delegate at work.